بالتاكيد ياكلنا للسؤال اذا كان تصليط
الضوء على هذه الفضيحه مرتبط
بشكل كبير او اكبر من اي مساله اخرى
بالعمليه الانتخابيه المرتقبه في تركيا ما
الذي يمنعها من ان تكون موضوع يومي مثير
الجدل
يوميا
في اعلام المعارضه ولكن في سياقه تركي فان
الدوره تتغير بشكل سريع
عدد من التطورات السياسيه الكبيره التي
حصلت خلال الثلاثه الماضيه ولهذا في
النقاشه العامه التاليه همم الذين
حكومه استبداديه
وتستغل الادوات القانونيه للاضاءه
المعارضه مؤخره كرتون القضيه ضد عمده
اسطنبول ولهذا فن الراي العام انتقل الى
المساله الجديده ولكن من الواضح ان مثل
هذه المساله باتت مواضيع هامه ورئيسيه
خاصه
الذين بما يجري في تركيا
[موسيقى]
ضد الحكومه بانتخابات القادمه ليس لدينا
الشك
حسن المعارضه
هذه المس اهلا خلال حملات انتخابيه